how do you convince people first of all
like
it's like you need youtube twitter and
facebook and
and every other company just to make a
hard stand and say no
we're allowing this we're done and then
allow the conversations to happen
so this is what we've been advocating
for quite a bit i mean mostly me but i
think
you know lydia agrees yeah form 230
reform section 230.
you're from you're familiar with that of
course i bet you know so how so in
what sense my so right now you saw what
trump did with the executive order
yeah uh can you can you explain to
people what section 230 is just yes
digital intermediaries who host user
generated content
have immunity certain degree of freedom
from
liability over the content um but
it doesn't actually say that you can't
moderate it says that you can you can
yeah right in
in good faith which is a problematic
term to put
into law i would say it says
essentially you know you can't hold
these platforms liable for other people
say
and these platforms can moderate so long
it's it's in good faith that they're
trying to remove objectionable lewd
lascivious
violent you know right or
in other ways objectionable content and
so all of a sudden now
you get twitter saying hashtag learn to
code is objectionable
well i just don't like the the bait and
switch the thing is that they
they all started as you know twitter
slogans free speech winning the free
speech party not anymore
anymore that was a joke they said you
know google don't be evil facebook
revolution starting in the middle east
from facebook everybody you know thought
that these were
for free speech and so they put years of
their lives into building up
followings there thinking that they and
they could say all this stuff for years
you know they could actually to a
certain i mean the content policies were
always pretty bad
in my opinion they never were like first
amendment focused
right but they were way better and so it
to me it's more false advertising
and right that is definitely grounds for
some legal action if i i have to imagine
when twitter started banning people for
saying learn to code
there's no reasonable person who would
consider that objectionable
no reasonable person they'd be like i
don't understand what does that mean
it's like oh it's a reference to getting
a job in the coding industry like what's
wrong with that
so how do how does twitter still have
section 230 protection
if they already are you know removing
content outside of the realm of what the
law allows
does someone just need to sue them to
like make it to get started
i think people are trying yeah but i
i know so trump has this executive order
they want to define what these terms
mean specifically maybe that's a first
step
what i'm what i'm thinking for section
230 is we definitely don't want to get
rid of it
we definitely need it but it should also
add a provision
saying illegal speech right
and that's specifically declaring
threats you know incitements to
direct violence you know announcing that
you are literally going
to go commit a crime or something but if
someone says
naughty words and stupid opinions that's
protected speech
i don't think i i think if let me know
what you think
because my assumption is if they amended
section 230 to say
you can remove content that is deemed
you know illegal
everything else it's fair game yeah i
mean that is one
path though then you are sort of forcing
you know like a a christian blog to
suddenly have to
keep content that they may i like i do
think that platforms should be able to
do what they want to do but it's all
about context and
the with which billions of people joined
i mean
well let's seriously let's actually
let's expand that because that's a
really good counterpoint
you're saying like if we change the law
this way then a christian blog that's
really small with only a small handful
of users gets inundated by a bunch of
people posting porn and they can't do
anything about it
right yeah yeah i think that that but i
also
you know look we're trying to build out
like blockchain
perma web storage so the content can't
even get deleted so you have the option
to
post to um this is a teaser for what's
probably coming out in the next
next month or so but there's a really
cool
block weave project called are weaving
so you'll be able to post to a totally
decentralized database that cannot
get taken down now the nodes in that
network can
choose to ignore certain content and
they do and they actually
have a pretty strict content policy but
certain nodes can always access they've
already backed up like all wikipedia and
archive wow
and yeah bro that's kind of scary though
man it is it is but it's sort of
um we're not forcing that but i
i do feel like you should have the
the option to sure i mean put it this
way
you sort of have to decide it's like a
task
what's scarier 1984 in the context
of everything is is permanent and known
or any everything can get burned 19
fahrenheit 451 or 1984.
is that what 1984 was like everything
was known like as a weapon
yeah it's more everything was known the
panopticon
look man what if you are you know 20 and
you're like
i think you know um what's it what's it
i can't think
what's it i think nickelback is great
and now you know that was a long time
ago today you're sitting there and
you're like i can't believe that will
exist forever
yeah i mean it exists in time and space
so
i don't know i mean but you shouldn't
have posted it i mean here's the thing
it's already
on the internet so you know it just came
out that
that instagram wasn't deleting anything
that people
were deleting for a year that just came
out i didn't hear about that so
um yeah it so people thought that it was
deleted
and it was not deleted and some hacker
researcher
figured it out and so you know even in
centralized databases like sometimes
it's hard
to delete data can you even delete data
exactly because i remember there's
tombstones there's all this stuff with
the way that the internet works like you
think that when you're walking around
the internet
you're just like you have some sort of
right to just
delete actions like rights to databases
yeah like it's not that easy even if you
wanted to i do think you should have the
ability to delete your content if you
if you want to but i mean like there
were hard drives in the world trade
center
that were smashed and burnt to a crisp
and they got data off them
right i see these stories i remember i
once did like a mass purge and like an
old computer
and i like rewrote it formatted it got
some special software
because i was doing this at a
hackerspace with like some friends
and then he insured me like this program
is going to be able to pull stuff off of
it
and we were able to pull off videos and
stuff and i'm like
i thought and it was probably more to do
with the fact that these things to
actually wipe the hard drives
don't so even if google even if facebook
you're like i would like to delete my
data they go you got it
and then it's it exists in other forms
you know about facebook's shadow
profiles
yeah so basically even if you don't use
the platform
they've collected so much data on you
from other people
you've got a shadow profile so how is
that any different from what tick tock
was doing
with their collection of the phone
numbers and everything giving it's not
that
different it's it's oh right giving it
to you but that's the thing
the tick tock band is
it's like you have to have standards
like why
just because it's i mean i i agree
they're doing super shady things
but there's plenty of u.s companies that
are easily selling data to china
and so it's like if you're going to have
surveillance standards have standards
don't just like pick an app but they can
control like so if there's a us company
doing that
if they want to they can step in and
just crush them with tick-tock operating
outside
they could crush them sort of in the u.s
like banning them and which is what
basically what they're trying to do
yeah now and trying to get microsoft to
trump microsoft
well twitter talked about buying tock
that's gonna be the stupidest thing i
ever heard
they shut down vine didn't they already
had
yeah what are they so dumb but i guess
tic tac is still a little different
i honestly don't trust that many of
these new social networks are real
anyway
i think they use that technique where
you create fake profiles
then you give young people fake
followers so they think they're they're
they get addicted to it they see the
number going up and they're like i'm
doing it i'm doing it and then they brag
to their friends look how many followers
i got and their friends join
and it's just a really easy and cheap
way to trick people into signing up
because i've seen without naming some of
these apps i've seen it very clearly
botting
and then i've seen people dedicate their
businesses to this stuff remember what
facebook was doing with facebook videos
oh just giving views based on nothing
yeah so
well i'll say my my understanding and
opinion for legal reasons
yeah basically so you put up a video the
number would be ridiculous
and then they would brag about how their
video views were bigger than youtube and
it was just it was
vanity numbers it wasn't real it was a
quick scroll by yup
yeah so i remember sitting down with
this big production company out of san
francisco i'm talking like one of the
biggest networks
and i said youtube man i was like
youtube's where it is youtube's where
it's at and i don't see that changing
and they were like i don't know man i'm
looking at these these facebook numbers
you gotta understand how crazy this is
and then i remember that actually came
to when i worked for fusion which was
the abc news company
straight up they had the conversation
and i said not facebook and
this guy's like yeah but listen man you
know these facebook numbers we're
looking at like
a million views on this video we just
did and i'm like they're it's not
you're not getting views bro then they
dedicate all this money into facebook
building out infrastructure for
production and then overnight it
crumbled in front of them
that's the scary thing and just they
just strangled the reach
yeah youtube is one of the few that has
maintained it seems like the their
default feed it is annoying they do not
go to chronological
but they do have the subscriptions feed
but it seems like the organic reach on
youtube
is better than other
social networks and you know it's smart
for any network to give lots of organic
reach
like you're going to retain people
longer over
in in the you know in the long run is it
if you if you created a reverse
chronological
social network wouldn't it just devolve
into lunacy and extremism
like if that's all it was i mean
it's based on who you subscribed to but
like
people would exploit the system people
would personally choose to create the
most bombastic and extreme content
that would get more shares and then
people would choose to subscribe to the
craziest people you know
like twitter basically yeah i but i
from a news perspective what you said
earlier i that's where i'm at
in terms of needing to feel confident
that you're going to have access to the
information that you've been expecting
to be able to get i you know i think
about the challenges of trying to run
these big networks and i think there is
it is fair
you know to be fair it's not there's no
simple solution
no man and algorithms are not bad it's
like that's like saying
math is bad you can't you know you know
what youtube used to be like in the
early days
it was all thumbnails of women in
bikinis i'm like half
kidding but it basically was a lot of it
was these short clips
that were just i mean it was kind of
like vine almost you know or tic-tock
these short clips
of funny viral moments charlie bit my
finger and things like that right
or you know goats screaming like humans
now it's 10
20 30 minute videos that's that's doing
well because youtube wanted to promote
more substantive content
so podcast started doing way better
politics started doing way better
and then the other issue is early on
when thumbnails it was all about if you
get clicks we show you
right the people who put up the bikini
women on their thumbnails got more
clicks than anybody else
but then you click the video and it'd be
some dude in his room talking about you
know i don't know
well that's the thing people are going
to yell at whatever social network it is
no matter what they do
so if people you know even if you don't
have some crazy algorithm that
feeds one political side and you just
feed
more of the video that you're of the
creator that you're watching
some people yell the network you're just
you know leading them down
the path of that person yeah it's like
basically any recommendation
is going to potentially have problems
associated with it
yeah but i don't know i think keeping it
simple what do you think is the best
recommendation for like how to run the
system of delivering content yeah
i don't know man you know i i think
social media is just a
busted system maybe we need to reimagine
it rebuild it
because right now you know we started
this conversation based on
the tearing down of statues and how many
of these
many of these people who are many on the
left who support this don't realize
they're tearing down they're
either tearing down george washington
they're tearing down you know um
priests they they're defacing jesus i'm
sure many of them don't care about that
but some of these people are uh
hans christian head for instance died
fighting two free
slaves they tore him down they someone
tore down frederick douglass
one of the most epic you know
anti-slavery dudes period
worked with harriet tubman this guy was
awesome they don't know this
because the algorithm won't show them
and so if you only do reverse
chronological
people still have confirmation bias they
probably still won't
engage you know yeah i think that
alternative feeds
that aren't reverse chronological can
still be
really valuable and maybe there could be
echo chamber breaking
algorithms that could feed you from both
sides libertarian
socialist democrat republican centrist
like
you know and you can you can train
feeds and have people train feeds we're
trying to work on
like a decentralized reputation system
you you've been really focused on
figuring out how to do fact checking as
well and i think that
if you can start to build
credibility in certain tags then like
do you think that your vote should be
higher than somebody else's vote in
journalism
topic on a certain social network me
personally
yeah probably not no not than some
random person
um probably a little bit more it's tough
because
it i don't know i don't know how to
answer that other than i don't like the
idea
because what ends up happening is you
you create a system where the new york
times
is considered more credible and then
what do we see with the covington kids
a wave of fake news none of them did any
work and we're supposed to trust these
people they're all verified
so twitter has created essentially this
the verified accounts are considered
more credible but what if it was based
purely on like peer-to-peer
voting it wasn't based on like
partisanship
i would have a really low i would have
an extremely low rating i'd have i
wouldn't i'd have a 50 50.
i would yeah the left would come to
brigade me and say false and
and you know moderates in the right
anti-w like the the two culture were
factions
they'd both be battling it out on my
page or someone else's with negative
you know comments and then it would be
like
50 50. but then you'd end up with some
random guy at the new york times with
100 followers
and all of his you know colleagues will
give him a thumbs up and it'll say 100
votes credible
tim poole 56 000 5050 and so people
wouldn't be able to determine
whether or not they would be like well
we know tim pool's uh
popular i guess like people know who he
is
but half the people don't like i think
it'd be to be fair a lot of leftists
wouldn't actually
i probably end up with like a 65 or 70
because a certain amount of leftists
would just
be spamming me because they hate me but
mostly they don't
bother with me do you think that it
would be
worthwhile information to have not to
say that necessarily
that was the you know end-all be-all
voting metric for you know what is
featured on the site but do you think it
would be interesting to
let the community vote on different
people's
credibility and different topics it
might be like an interesting might be
secondary metric
might be fun to try it yeah just to see
what happens i've talked about it in the
past
you know what uh and and that was the
first thing that was brought up to me
was you would just get the left
attacking any conservative they would
they would they have these
you know email lists they have these
twitter accounts you'd get one of these
twitter accounts with 400 000 followers
and they would say everybody
tweet negative on this guy and then all
of a sudden one day you got a guy with
10 000 followers
you know 8 000 thumbs up a thousand
thumbs down
really great rating and then one day 30
000 people from one of these activist
sites or twitter accounts just thumbs
down and now it's like 10
credibility and so people are like whoa
this guy's really bad
yeah there would have to be some sort of
decaying
mechanism for mobs yep
it'd have to be something you know how
do you check
that's it's tough because they're going
to brigade people they like and i don't
know if there's a way an algorithm can
determine
unless like you make an algorithm that
searches for certain words that only
appear on the left
so you know how the stock exchange
freezes if it drops more than a certain
number of points
in a certain range of time you could
install something like that
and just say if you drop more than a
certain amount over the course of maybe
a day
then we can pause it until after you're
done exactly yeah like
the mob i don't know man nice i have no
idea that's my thought
we kind of went off on a tangent on that
one about algorithms though but it was a
good conversation
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you